I disappear for two days in the world
falls apart Pennsylvania Attorney
General Josh Shapiro graphically and
meticulously details decades and decades
of sexual abuse by Catholic priests
against children and teenagers in a
grand jury report the scandal has had
effects all the way up to the College of
Cardinals this is a once in a century
problem if not more and there's gonna be
a lot more pain we will analyze why it
happened and what can be done about it
then the dumbest article on the internet
this week care of slate I'm shocked
totally shocked it was slate then former
Bush administration drug czar John
Walters stops by to discuss the opioid
epidemic legalized Haitian oregano and
why libertarians are wrong some of my
favorite topics finally the mailbag I'm
Michael knodel's and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
okay so you if you can notice the bags
under the bags under the bags under my
eyes
it's because we got in last night pretty
late from Phoenix we were out in Dallas
and Phoenix for the Ben Shapiro live
shows and it was so much fun it was
great I got to meet a lot of people in
both cities people were flying down from
Canada they were flying in from Boston
and just all over the place that one guy
came from Alaska so it's really cool it
was so good to meet everybody and one
thing that is not surprising I knew it
just from the mailbag and from meeting
other people you know in different
cities is that the daily wire listeners
and viewers are so much smarter than the
average people you know then certainly
than your average New York Times reader
or an NBC viewer CNN viewer or something
like that but they're really smarter
some of these questions were
extraordinarily erudite the people that
I met our interesting people they've got
excellent education they've got
interesting jobs they work in
interesting industries and they're just
really smart I mean there were questions
about Aristotle and Thomas Aquinas and
David Hume and it was really great I
really really enjoyed that and even you
know we go to college campuses and you
would think that would be the smartest
audience these are people who were in in
the throes of studying who were being
educated and but really it was the
people at these events many of whom I've
also met on college campuses or am going
to meet this fall who were clearly
they've continued their education after
they've got out of less leftist
indoctrination centers they've maybe
they've begun their education after that
so it was really nice great to meet
everybody out there and I hope that we
come to a city near you soon because
there's a lot of fun we've got to get to
just the Catholic Church imploding and
all the horrible things that have
happened since I've been gone for 48
hours
before we do that we could all use a
little coffee to get into all of that I
could use a little cough FA out of which
I've I think now is legal there or maybe
that's illegal they're legalizing pot
but they're banning cough FA in Los
Angeles one thing they haven't banded
yet is black rifle coffee if you have
ever found yourself wincing at the weak
taste of coffee from those left-leaning
straw banning
corporate brands you know I'm talking
about you have an idea who I'm talking
about you probably thought I wish they
spent less time on meaningless bias
training those racist coffee houses you
know and you probably wish that they
spent less time making your the
bathrooms acceptable to all 75,000
genders and you know they defy common
sense that's why you need black rifle
coffee I drink black rifle coffee every
day I love it it is absolutely delicious
which is the most important thing
because they're great they I've talked
to the guys who run it
they are super cool guys they support
veteran causes they support first
responder causes so your money is going
to do good things but frankly look we're
Americans we're capitalists the most
important thing is this has to be the
best cup of coffee
and it is it is so good and you'll feel
like a real cool guy when you drink it
they have great coffee they have great
gear they have a coffee club that makes
things really easy no lines no running
out just great coffee shipped right to
your door every month hassle-free and
and you get to support good veteran and
first responder causes instead of I
don't know Planned Parenthood we refer
the other coffee companies are donating
to black rifle it's delicious go to
black rifle coffee dot-com slash cough
fa co v fe fe don't say I never did
nothing for you get 15% off your first
order I think it might be 15% off any of
your orders so but that certainly your
first one and your first won't be your
last
go to black rifle coffee calm / co f f/a
co v fe fe 15% off that's pretty good
black rifle coffee calm / go FFA co v fe
fe you're gonna love it it is superb
coffee okay now that I've got my coffee
I've got my coffee I'll take one last
sip let's get into this absolutely
horrific news cycle and we can talk
we'll have to talk about the Catholic
sex scandal because it is so egregiously
horrific I was sitting backstage last
night for the pre-show in Arizona at Ben
Shapiro live and I was reading the
thousand page grand jury report at a
Pennsylvania that details decades and
decades and decades of just the most
horrific abuse you can imagine or that
you can't imagine
just not a great way to get ready for a
show it's not doesn't really put you in
the entertaining spirit but you've
really got to you've really got to read
this I highly recommend you read this
you know you can you can skim it it's
not like war and peace or something a
lot of this is in legal language and you
know these these things are really
horrific and it's great work from
Pennsylvania Attorney General Josh
Shapiro will put this in broader context
everybody knows the sex scandal of the
early 2000s this was the first real
breaking of the widespread abuse in the
Catholic Church which should not be
taken to mean that there isn't
widespread or wider spread abuse in
other churches in other denominations in
other religions or in non religious
institutions we'll get to that later but
it really broke in the Catholic Church
and it's really horrific I can speak to
this a little bit personally I always
wanted to be an altar boy when I was a
kid and the sex scandal broke around the
time that I could have become an altar
boy and I wasn't allowed to become an
altar boy and I wasn't allowed to I
wasn't allowed to know why I mean that's
not like the your parents explain this
to you when you're 8 or 10 years old
they say you can't because there's this
widespread sex abuse problem you just
said I couldn't do it and this was a
couple years before I became an atheist
for a decade but it did coincide around
the same time and I'm not saying that
the sex abuse problem caused my atheism
I certainly had no conscious thought of
that but you know evil begets evil evil
spreads and pervades the environment so
there-there is coincidental timing there
has real effects because it turns people
against God it turns people against
their church and against God whole
generations I mean it's it's so so
wicked so that's a little bit of the
context here last month or a couple
months ago a major Cardinal Cardinal
McCarrick
resigned from the College of Cardinals
because of sex abuse allegations and
this guy he was a lefty Cardinal but was
a member of the College of Cardinals and
a very well known figure and he was
kicked out mostly for abusing
seminarians I think there was one or two
allegations that he abused an altar boy
who was 16 in decades ago but from
priests friends of mine have talked to
them they knew about Cardinal McCarrick
not about abusing a 16 year old boy but
about pressuring seminarians and other
priests and sexually abusing them
I had a priest pal of mine say that
Cardinal McCarrick hit on him when he
was a seminarian and he didn't know it
that you know these things are a little
ambiguous so you don't know but it was
well talked about that he was not that
he was abusing boys or teenagers but
that he was pressuring priests and
seminarians like the me2 movement of the
church you know there have been rumors
about this guy for awhile then they came
out this was the first Cardinal to
resign from the College of Cardinals
since 1927 since a monarchist Cardinal
resigned for political reasons
once-in-a-century sort of thing
major a major incident and that sets up
this past week where we've seen this
Attorney General report a thousand child
victims child and teenage victims over
at 60 or 70 years by 301 priests and the
Attorney General says they don't think
they got all the priests they clearly
got a lot of them you know probably most
of them are the vast majority but a
thousand victims now I the the photos
the the photos that are described the
rituals that are described the incidence
that are described are so horrific I'll
just give you a few of them because they
give you a sense of the character of
this they these priests would correspond
and collude with one another in one case
they took a boy and they had him posed
naked as Christ on the cross so it's not
just that they hadn't posed naked and
they created child pornography it isn't
just this fleshy thing and this is the
aspect of this I think a lot of people
are not quite registering if it's just
some sexual deviant priests some
perverts who want to satisfy the flesh I
can kind of I can at least comprehend it
I can understand okay there's sexual
deviance and they use their uh their
opportunity to get what they want
what's even more horrifying is the
spiritual component of it the utter
sacrilege the The Satanic character of
this
it wasn't enough to take photos of this
little boy they had to take photos of
him mocking Christ on the cross they had
to there was one case of a priest who
abused a boy and then washed his mouth
out with holy water didn't use bottled
water didn't use tap water holy water
and at the the satanic character of all
of this one priest used a crucifix a
seven inch long crucifix to abuse a boy
why why that character the the question
of why and the answer to that question
is gives us an unpopular answer but it
gives us the answer to why this is going
on so why is this going on first you
know I always look for the bright side
of things hard to find a bright side or
a silver lining in this but the if there
is to be any good news in this it's
abyss that the vast majority of these
priests are dead they're already dead
that's a very good thing they're dead
because I think the headlines make us
think that there are that there have
been a thousand kids abused in the last
few years this hasn't really happened
very much at all in the last few years
or even the last decade or two the these
incidents go back to 1947 so if a priest
abused somebody in 1947 chances are they
died a long long time ago many many of
these priests died decades ago so they
some I was talking about this with a
friend of mine he said so they escaped
their punishment I said I don't think so
something tells me they're getting their
punishment right now and you can't can't
predict these things but I bet those
priests knew they were getting their
punishment too so there's a silver
lining in that at least that of the vast
majority of them are dead or have been
defrocked or whatever these cases also
took place in the 1960s 70s and 80s the
majority of them there were some that
were more recent there were some that
were earlier than that but the big bulk
of these were in those decades those
decades around the sexual revolution
which I suppose should not be surprising
and it's good that they the vast
majority of them happened a long time
ago
so what is the issue now what is to be
done now how what do we blame for this a
lot of people want to blame celibacy
this is the kind of this is the
gut-wrenching answer
the simple answer the intuitive answer
that well priests can't have sex so
they're gonna become sexual deviants
this doesn't really hold up to scrutiny
or all of the social scientific data
show that celibacy not just in the
Catholic Church but in other religions
doesn't have a link to sex abuse against
children who are against anybody else
there's really no correlation there have
been a number of studies about this
there was a major five-year study by the
John Jay College of Criminal Justice at
the City University of New York excuse
me
another possibility is that it's
homosexuality I say well there all these
gay priests yeah from priests that I've
spoken to they're all there are a lot of
gay priests I talked to one priest he
said well if we if we just simply get
rid of all that gay priests there won't
be there won't be any priests left we
would have any priests in the church and
the question I don't think is about
priests who have ever attracted to
members of the same sex
it's obviously priests who are acting
out their sexual desires there were
there are plenty of girls and women who
were mentioned in that report in
Pennsylvania though the majority were
boys and young men so again a dad study
and other study shows that there's not
really a link between homosexuality and
sex abuse against children now the
majority of the victims are boys and
teens but that might teenage boys but
that might suggest that that just there
are a lot of gay priests I don't know it
doesn't seem to me that the answer quite
lies there though the mainstream media
want to run with this Washington Post
ran a headline the Catholic Church is
enabling the sex abuse crisis by forcing
gay priests to stay in the closet GK
Chesterton said the Catholic Church the
way he knew it was the church is because
it gets attacked for opposite reasons so
on the one hand that's saying they're
saying that they force gay priests in
the closet on the other hand people are
criticizing and saying they're allowing
gay priests to be open and to flourish
okay again I don't think that quite gets
to the problem by the way it's also
worth pointing out that there's this
question of is it just something about
Catholics it's just something about the
Catholic faith that breeds child abuse
or pederasty or whatever this the data
don't really back this up one study
shows that this problem of child abuse
is no more widespread in the Catholic
Church
than it is among the general male
population the rates are actually lower
the National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children backs this up they
say there is nothing particularly
Catholic faith that they see the same
rates of abuse among other religious
groups and other Christian denominations
insurance companies that cover many
denominations say that the problem is
not especially Catholic they see it in
Protestant denominations they see it you
know evangelical churches and
denominations as well so I guess we
can't pinpoint it on that also there's a
report prepared number of years ago for
the US Department of Education that
shows that sex abuse by school teachers
is a hundred times more prevalent than
sex abuse by Catholic priests which
makes perfect sense we see those
headlines all the time although frankly
the media do focus more on it when it's
religious figures and especially when
it's Catholics okay but still shouldn't
we expect more of our priests than we do
have the general male population or than
we expect of school teachers or
something of course and this is worse
for reasons beyond that why is this so
much worse it just we just know that
this is so much worse on the one
certainly because it breaks people's
relationship to God and it breaks
people's relationship to their church
forever it poisons people against God
for generations but it's just the evil
character of it it's it's that it's so
wicked the evil seems so gratuitous why
why did why does the little boy in the
picture have to mock Christ on the cross
why did the priests make him do that
why do they have to use holy water where
do they have to use crucifixes why is
this so evil why is it so a sacrilegious
and satanic and evil that's the answer
it reminds me of Ephesians 4 we wrestle
not against flesh and blood but against
principalities against powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places that's the issue spiritual
wickedness and this gets to the answer
father get Gabriele Amorth who was the
Vatican's chief Exorcist for a quarter
of a century he wrote a number of years
ago that the devil resides in the
Vatican and we're seeing the
consequences of it now we are seeing the
consequences
now what does it mean for the devil to
reside in the Vatican it means that evil
exists evil has a personality you know
there was this couple this American
couple who decided that evil doesn't
exist the the boyfriend wrote on his
blog he said evil is just make-believe
we've just invented evil to describe
people who have different values than we
do in different opinions but evil it's
not really real and they went on this
bike tour of the world and they were say
we're gonna go to Africa and North
Africa in the Middle East and nobody's
gonna be evil because it's all so nice
and we're living in kumbaya land right
and on day 369 of their journey they
were going through Tajikistan and a car
passed them the car did a u-turn the car
mowed them down and then Muslim
terrorists got out and stabbed both of
them to death the the boyfriend and the
girlfriend stabbed them to death
because evils not make-believe evil is
real and most importantly evil has a
personality
evil has a personality and that's the
devil that's the the person that we call
the devil and Pete Scott people scoff at
that these days self-styled
sophisticates scoff at the devil Antonin
Scalia did this great interview with New
York Magazine this flippant little girl
reporter and she said oh gosh you
believe in the devil huh that's got to
be awful scary and he said do you know
how out of touch you are not only with
the majority of America who believes in
the devil but with the majority of
people threat history everybody's
believed in the devil and here's the
money quote many more intelligent people
than you and I have believed in the
devil because the devil is real and the
devil resides in the vatican where else
would the devil be where else if you
were the devil where would you stage
your attack where where else but the
Vatican Scalia was right about many
things it reminds me he gave he gave
this quote to Lesley Stahl one time on
CBS do we have it of Antonin Scalia
explaining his point of view that's my
view and it happens to be correct my
view and it happens to be correct that
is the view and and if we deny that if
we continue to deny the existence of
people on the personality people will
never get to this you're gonna hear a
calls for a lot of reform movements from
the left you're gonna hear calls that we
need to let priests be gay the openly
gay and sexual sexually active we need
to let priests marry we need to let
priests whatever this on that you're
gonna hear from the the right that we
need to just just simply getting rid of
gay priests that's gonna solve the
problem with priests who were attracted
to member
of the same sex or just getting rid of
these bad Cardinals would be is gonna
solve the problem and what getting rid
of bad bishops and Cardinals will will
help the problem but it won't solve the
problem it won't get to the heart of the
problem because everybody especially in
modern society they want some policy
what's the policy that's gonna then
we're gonna do one little policy and
then all of this evil is gonna go away
it's not how it works
there's no policy there is no policy to
fix it
there can be attorneys general in the
states who can follow the lead of Josh
Shapiro and that would be very good for
their political careers and it would be
morally good because it would root out
these guys who should hang from a rope
that would be good or who were already
getting their eternal desserts down
below that would that would be a good
good thing to happen but there's no
policy there's no policy that's gonna
there's no easy switch if we're tweet
treating this as a problem of the flesh
this isn't a problem of the flesh it's a
problem of spiritual wickedness in high
places it's a problem of evil and it's a
problem of the person of evil it's a
problem of the devil if we deny that
we're not gonna not only fail to fix the
problem but the evil is going to fester
we're running late so I'm gonna have to
skip the worst stupidest article on the
internet but I really did want to
address that because because it's a
problem in my church so I figured we
should talk about it let's skip that
let's get right to another another issue
going on which is Americans who want to
legalize every drug and I hear that you
hear this from libertarians all the time
and say legalize everything and then you
hear I look and I see billboards that
say get Haitian oregano delivered
directly to your door you know a little
Peruvian parsley coming right to your
door click of an app and people are
celebrating this and meanwhile we have
an opioid epidemic wreaking havoc all
across the country I got to sit down
with a good friend of mine and a former
teacher of mine and the former drug czar
for the Bush administration John Walters
he's not a CEO at the Hudson Institute
he's the head of the Hudson Political
Studies Program and he's just a
brilliant guy all around and especially
on matters of drug policy so here John
Walters dispels all of the stupid
slogans that we hear about a drug policy
without further ado i sat down with John
Walters mr. Walters thank you so much
for being here thank you Michael good to
see you so your skills and your
expertise are more
demand now than ever we there's the
opioid crisis as taking over the whole
country
the statistics are really horrifying
just sort of seemingly random statistics
pregnant women who are addicted to
opioids has quadrupled in the last eight
or nine years you know it's it's spread
coast to coast and all throughout the
middle of the country from your position
having you know shaped so much of
national drug policy what can the
government do what can the government
not do what are the limits of government
reach and where did everything go so
wrong
well it's weird territory we've never
been before they're just the biggest
numbers we have our overdose deaths and
those lag in reporting the last full
number we have is 2016 over 60,000
overdose deaths we've never we've never
had that kind of carnage in this country
before the numbers have been growing at
almost 20% a year and that's just the
deaths that's not the addiction that's
not the use that's not the overdoses
that don't result in death
we're not even tracking that effectively
so we are so asleep at the switch on
this that it's very difficult to craft a
response because you don't know where it
is
now you don't know what the magnitude is
and there are things we can do but we
have to do the things at the place where
they're going to make a difference and
we're not even measuring that so this
got very bad after the first wave was
added by to a second wave was added to a
third way the first wave being in terms
of opioids pain medication that was
diverted beginning well over 10 15 years
ago a failure of medical institutions to
properly look at the research and to
respond quickly when I was drug policy
director for President George W Bush we
started to see some of this and we tried
to work with FDA to get get some control
on the misuse and diversion the argument
at that time was pain was a new human
right to be free from pain was necessary
and if we didn't do that by giving
people powerful medications we were
doing something immoral
when became clear
it should have been earlier but when it
finally became overwhelmingly clear that
these were being misused in large
numbers then we began to kind of change
the dimensions of of some of the threat
but you know in the absence of that it
was it was simply more and more people
getting sicker and sicker added to that
was subsequently about 2010 a doubling
of heroin production in Mexico it then
continued to grow that added additional
deaths and ditional addiction and then
added to that again not receding and
then added added to that was the
fentanyl flow into the United States
most of it coming either directly from
China through Mexico or through Parcel
Post some of it through precursors that
were then cooked in Mexico so we have
simply had institutions that failed
failed to protect us at the border
failed to protect us from foreign
sources and criminal networks failed to
protect us with health and and and
treatment data that can be used
effectively we're still not there and
when I talk to government officials here
in the administration in Congress the
first thing I tell them is you have to
get better information so you can focus
resources otherwise the the the the harm
simply grows you focused a lot on the
production side of it and I wonder how
much is how much is supply and how much
is demand there's you know heroin
there's fentanyl coming over from Mexico
there are these apparently lazy doctors
who are not very conscientious the
medical professionals who are letting
these drugs be misused or they're being
overprescribed or they're being diverted
but how much of this is a as a demand
issue you know you see suicides
skyrocketing in the country you do see a
sort of cultural trouble there's a
there's a cultural issue it seems like
people are anxious and nervous and there
there seems to be a pervasive
subjectivism or nihilism or just some
cultural problem how much of this is
being caused by the the demand of people
who just want to apply themselves with
more drugs and how much can we just
blame on bad guys and criminals
producing more and
poisoning our country I think that's a
central issue Michael and I think we are
obviously in the midst of something
where people initiate this by beginning
to use drugs obviously that it starts by
use it continues this is a this is a
disease phenomenon but it's a disease
phenomenon where the victim has to
continue to take the drugs in order to
be victimized however having done this
for a long time and I started out in the
Department of Education during the
Reagan administration working on drugs
with Bill Bennett I worked in both Bush
41 and Bush 43 I don't think there's a
living person who successfully argued
for more prevention and treatment money
than I have in my lifetime at the
federal level but having said all that
my view now looking at the terrible
situation we are now in which as I said
is historically without precedent is we
have embedded in our culture a tolerance
of this that is impossible for us to
eradicate that is going back to the baby
boomers my generation it was
it's now been come I've kind of accepted
that well everybody tells you not to do
this your parents or the people at home
you go on the internet you watch popular
culture you you hear what people say and
it's you're supposed to experiment with
this this is the edgy thing to do and we
actually I reach to run an anti-drug
media campaign when I was in Bush
administration the last time and we did
a lot of surveys of youth and some of
those were for kids to keep track of the
messages they got about drugs or
two-week period write them down every
time it happened essentially the
findings of that was it was 12 to 1 use
drugs everybody uses drugs here's how to
use drugs here's why it's cool
versus don't so I think the problem we
have is when people say we have to stop
demand I don't think we have a viable
way to stop the man moreover these drugs
these substances can addicting they're
our biological nature makes it such that
these these substances can cause
addiction and dependency not only for
humans we know they can does it for
monkeys and rats and mice we addictive
for research purposes so when these
poisons I think it's much better to
think about this as a mass poisoning
incident when these poisons are in our
culture they make victims and they're
aggressively marketed by criminal
organizations that are network
phenomenon like terrorist networks they
have to be torn down and in fact if you
look back the meth epidemic here when we
had small toxic labs people cooking it
themselves it wasn't until we stopped
those labs it wasn't until we reduce the
flow of cocaine out of Colombia when
President rebei was president that we
reduced by 60% cocaine use it wasn't
until we stopped the heroin coming out
of Colombia and reduced the heroin
coming out of Mexico that we reduced
heroin use it wasn't until now we're
controlling some of the prescription
diversion that we reduce the
prescription victimization which is
still too high so my argument is if you
look back historically we've only been
able to stop this when we stopped the
poison and we we should encourage
prevention we obviously want to treat
people who are victims but this is like
if you say just prevention and treatment
it's like trying to stop terrorist
attacks by building Shock Trauma wounds
you're not going to stop them we need
them what we need to treat people but we
need to stop the poisoning first that's
a great point and it injects some
reality into the drug discussion and the
drug debate so often it seems to be had
at this utterly abstract ethereal level
but we're talking about real poisons on
the ground coming in through real
borders and real ports of entry in real
places and from real criminal gangs now
you're you're a very busy guy you've
always kept busy and one of the many
things that you do is run the Hudson
Institute political studies program and
when I was a student of yours in that
program I remember a lot of young people
libertarian types and conservatives they
they would frequently tell you
everything about drug policy they had
you know they probably hadn't studied it
that for they were I didn't have a lot
of experience they say no don't worry I
know this very well we should legalize
everything freedom freedom freedom baby
but one why is this view so widely
spread on the right and - why why is it
wrong well it's interesting I was
talking to a conservative columns I
won't name that person because they're
known but at
fourth of July event and in the course
of it they mentioned to me that well of
course I believe we should legalize
drugs and I said really at sixty-five
thousand deaths a year and climbing you
think that we need more of this I said
look yeah young people because they live
in a culture where drugs are pervasive
and they see a lot about it they believe
they've seen they've seen what they need
to make a judgement right um in addition
I thought one time so now I you know I
write I know I know about drug policy
well I I know people that use it and the
President Obama used it used cocaine
said it was a bad habit he was president
the United States were a problem well of
course these are phenomenon where it
doesn't harm you every time you use it
but it harms a significant number of
people when they use it in on a repeated
basis or when they use it in the normal
course of what use looks like in the
United States today
it can start frequently with marijuana
and it does for most people if the
bottom of the funnel is overdose death
and the middle of the funnel is
addiction the top of the funnel is
experimentation and most of that starts
with marijuana and the danger that we're
facing now is we already have a worse
death rate than we've ever had in this
country and we're aggressively expanding
the top of the funnel by making
marijuana ubiquitous in more and more
places at the time when it's being
marketed with more potent varieties so I
think they get the precise part of your
question is the libertarian position
presumes that a rational person should
take responsibility for the decisions
that they make the problem with these
substances is they impair reason they
impair choice they make people subject
to a chemical dependency that Lou they
lose control of their lives
we the reality of this I think if you
really want to look at the reality is
look what people do to themselves their
lives collapse down into using drugs
seeking drugs they'll do anything
they'll do me they'll degrade themselves
they'll steal from their own family
they'll they'll become involved in
criminal activity for the purposes of
seeking these drugs the power of these
drugs over individuals varies it varies
over time it varies by genetic factors
but everybody could be victim and those
that are are not rational independent
actors that's my argument with my
libertarian friends I don't want a nanny
state I worked a lot in Republican
government agencies and governments
administration's to improve education
improves the programs and disadvantage
by getting some of the bureaucratic
bloat and they and the and the enemies
of freedom away from the people who are
vulnerable but substance abuse what I
libertarian friends don't seem to
understand is substance abuse takes away
the power of freedom it's the opposite
of Liberty it's the opposite of
independent self-government that's a
it's such a good point it creates
slavery and so when the
eighteen-year-old kid says I've smoked
pot one time I know about national drug
policy they're there they're missing all
of the effects of drugs on the person
regular use habitual use it just it does
degrade Liberty you can't you're you're
not you're not in control of yourself
and you're not not only are you're not
in control of your faculties you're not
you're not in control of judgment you
really lose this even Jim Morrison no
anti-drug guy himself you know lead
singer of the doors Jim Morrison did an
anti-drug PSA one time and he said well
when you're when I'm on this drug I
can't think at all is like I love if Jim
Morrison can gather that maybe maybe
other people should too you know I
before I let you go I look around I'm in
Los Angeles la-la land
I see giant billboards for marijuana
delivery services come right to your
door there's probably an app for that
now there are votes all over the country
to legalize so decriminalize certainly
marijuana and then there are pushes for
other drugs too do you see the culture
moving in this sort of irreversibly
prodrug direction or is there some way
to turn the culture around look
I think you just look at the science
here it's just a biological fact that
human beings if they use these
substances enough times become dependent
mmm it's also true they go from one
substance to another substance because
they get used to being dependent you
asked about the so-called deaths of
despair I think a lot of that is actual
drug use if you drain the drugs out I'm
not saying it nobody will have despair
I'm not saying suicide will drop all
entirely but the parallel and the places
where this is happening are the places
that have been infected with drug use
including marijuana use all the science
about marijuana over the last 15 to 20
years not when I was young when people
were we're toting this as hay it's just
it's not reefer madness it's really
harmful it's natural it's it's it's a
way of expanding your consciousness it's
bits as good as alcohol and and and
better all the science has shown greater
dependency serious
causing and triggering serious mental
illness depression thoughts of suicide
psychosis regular and heavy use in young
adulthood can cause a permanent IQ loss
of seven points now for smart people
that went to Yale and and and Harvard
seven probably doesn't make much
difference maybe you could have been an
honor student at a State College instead
of Harvard or Yale although I don't know
mr. Walters I don't know if you've
looked around the Yale campus these days
I don't know it's a little dicey it's a
little shaky well for an average IQ
that's a difference between being able
to get a reasonably nice job or maybe a
white-collar job and being somebody who
has to mow lawns for the rest of their
life so the consequences for this we're
not even seeing we're not even measuring
what's going on here but all the science
science that's been done researched
longitudinal studies with twins to
control for genetic differences have
shown in other countries as well as the
United States have shown the dangers
here are even greater as we are
expanding marijuana and we're expanding
cannabis use we're allowing it in
concentrations never seen before not
three four five but 20% 30% more
addictive more dangerous so the problem
that we have is how many people are
going to become victims before we see
what we've done and begin to undo it I
think
we we need to we need to be able to get
more information to people right now
about what's happening for this but I do
I am fearful about what's happening in
California and other places because I I
spent more time in treatment centers
than most people talking to the victims
here and I can tell you that the law I
can I can I can I have a sense of the
lives that are being put at risk the
families the futures that are being
compromised here and the people who go
on to become casualties and statistics
and the devastating effect of that when
you go in two places in Ohio or
Pennsylvania and other places where this
is a progressed where opioid deaths are
overwhelming you know they don't really
want to talk about inequality of income
they don't really want to talk about
foreign policy they don't really want to
talk about what happens to deregulation
in the United States or what happens to
self-freedom they want to talk about how
do we stop losing our neighbors and our
family members so I think that's gonna
make this comeback and the fact is many
of those are battleground states and
politicians and I think both President
Trump and I think Secretary Clinton were
educated by this by having to go into
those states but the problem is we have
not come to grips with the fact that we
need to stop this substance from coming
in and I will say one last thing the
thing that shows you we can and should
do something in this a failure of
institution is most drugs killing
Americans today are coming from outside
the United States most of those pass
across the southwest border and most of
those pass within six feet of a uniform
federal agent that's a monumental
failure of intelligence and operations
and we can do a much better job not uh
not saying we go to zero but this isn't
a needle in the haystack this is a
pickup struck in a haystack that is such
a good point and of course it's an
important point from an electoral
perspective as well there is it's great
to talk about reforming entitlements
it's great to talk about all of these
things that we really care about but
people are seeing people die I I know
multiple people who have who have been
caught up in the opioid crisis and
unfortunately died and I'm from the
coasts you know I and I'm not from the
places that are hardest hit by by this
crisis really well it's really important
it's so good to get some actual
knowledge
this topic because people are just
talking in nonsense and ignorance so
it's so good to get some expertise and
we're gonna have to bring you back
because another area where you're
working hard to fix the country is in
education and supplementing the poor
education people are getting on
universities and it works for me too so
we're going to we'll have to have you
back on to talk about that some other
time
thank you Michael I spend half my time
on the American dream and half on the
American Nightmare
good mr. wall just good to see you and I
will talk to you soon thank you alright
I've gotta say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube obviously we're running very
late
I've got like I don't know seven or
eight minutes left I want to get through
seven or eight questions so we're gonna
fly through them you got to go to daily
wire.com if you want to watch that
by the way our next episode of the
conversation is almost here Tuesday
August 24th but 21st of August 21st 5:30
Eastern 2:30 Pacific I'll answer all of
your questions with our host Alicia
Krause the live Q&A will be available on
YouTube and Facebook for everyone to
watch but only subscribers can ask me
questions at daily wire.com go there
right now look you'll get me at the end
reclaim and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag which we read to get - none of
that matters what really matters is the
leftist tears tumblr look you know this
is the only we were just talking with
the former drug czar of the Bush
administration this is the only
fda-approved vessel for left us tears
they are overflowing these days make
sure you go daily we're calm we'll be
right back with a mailbag
hold on to your seats baby we are about
to fly I want everyone in the room hold
on we're about to fly if you're driving
pull over this is gonna be a lot your
heart is gonna flutter first question
from Bridget Michael I've been chatting
with an atheist online about this nation
being founded on Christian principles
one of the things he brought up is the
Treaty of Tripoli oh here we go here we
go
may 26 1797 article 11 which states as
the government of the United States of
America is not in any sense founded on
the Christian religion as it has in
itself no character of enmity against
the laws religion or tranquility of
muscleman that's a word for Muslims and
as the said states never have entered
into any war or active hostility against
any [ __ ] nation it is declared by
the parties that no pretext arising from
religious opinions shall ever produce an
interruption of the harmony existing
between the two countries he argues this
is proof positive that we're not a
Christian nation or a nation founded on
Christian principles I believe this is
more proof that the founders did not
want to ensconce a state religion but
isn't evidence at all against our nation
being fed on Christian principles
thoughts yeah it's not proof of either
of those it's proof that we wanted
Muslims to stop stealing and enslaving
our sailors that's what it's proof of if
if this were true if this were really
the founding philosophy of the United
States it we wouldn't find it in the
Treaty of Tripoli which was to make sure
that Muslim pirates of the Barbary Coast
wouldn't keep just stealing our goods
and our people and our ships you'd find
it in the Declaration of Independence or
in the Constitution or in the Federalist
Papers you'd find it somewhere there you
don't find it there you find it in this
treaty this obscure article of this
obscure treaty that was just designed so
that piece this other religion would
would stop capturing our people
obviously this nation is founded on
Christianity all of the people who
founded it were Christians they came
from a Christian culture some of them
were a little de istic but even deism
even enlightenment deism comes out of
christianity the the the pilgrims at
Plymouth
were Christian religious zealots John
Adams said our country was founded for a
moral religious people it's wholly unfit
for anybody else he's not talking about
Muslims he's not talking about Hindus
he's not talking about Buddhists he's
talking about the religion that they
come out of Christianity where he's
talking about a shining city on a hill
though the shiny city on a hill
we talk about when we refer to America
that the speech is not called a shining
city on a hill it's called a model of
Christian charity anybody who is citing
article 11 of a treaty to save our ships
and our sailors from Muslim pirates to
prove that this country isn't Christian
is being disingenuous they're obviously
being disingenuous look at all of
American history next question Nicholas
dear best-selling author Michael my
friend is in the process of converting
some high school girl to Christianity
just like a random high school girl just
like troll in high schools cruising high
schools to win souls I guess that's not
terrible it can might get a little weird
but not terrible there are close to they
are close to accepting Christianity but
they're still having some doubts about
the existence of God because they
believe that science conflicts with the
existence of God how would you go about
explaining that science doesn't disprove
the existence of God thanks Nick it
doesn't I don't know how are you going
to prove that there isn't a giant UFO
outside waiting to zap you when you walk
out there's no evidence of that
whatsoever so the the burden of proof is
and the people who say that just ask
them questions this is the way to deal
with people who's a stupid slogans such
as that but can't really back any of
that up okay you say that science
disproves God how so and then they'll
say some nonsense and then you disprove
that it doesn't it simply doesn't if
anything natural science speaks to the
Creator so it speaks for the creator of
nature so you know tell them you got to
give me something guys I can't I can't I
can't prove to you that there isn't an
elephant waiting out to crush me when I
walk out the door but there isn't an
elephant waiting out to crush me on a
walk out the door II can't you can't
disprove all the stupid ideas in the
world you you it's the burden of proof
is on them for a measurement hello
Michael I was wondering what your take
is as a religious person on ghosts
walking the earth
I used to dismiss the idea of spirits
and ghostly events due to silly TV shows
and whatnot I've been rethinking my
position however after hearing stories
from a close friend whom I don't believe
to be crazy about his old house also as
I become more religious and believe in
the afterlife I'm questioning if there
is an afterlife if it can somehow
collide with I our life here what are
your thoughts on ghosts and does
believing in ghosts contradicts
Christianity or Catholicism thanks
Benjamin well to quote mr. Shakespeare
there are more things between heaven and
earth that are dreamt of in our
philosophy that's certainly true there
a supernatural world a metaphysical
world world beyond just the flesh
absolutely true I don't think that
ghosts are around here haunting me
but demons are there are demons there
are Devils prowling the earth trying to
ruin souls and this is a traditional
explanation for what people would think
are ghosts or something like that is
that there's evil there's spiritual evil
in the world that seeks to lie to you
the devil is a liar and a murderer from
the very beginning and we're seeing
we're seeing that very clearly these
days and so that's what I would suspect
I you know that the devil proscribes
going to seances or doing astrology or
talk trying to talk to spirits not
because it's all bunk but because it's
evil it's evil and compromises your
freewill and you're talking to some bad
hombres to quote President Trump I
wouldn't try talking to ghosts or
anything like that talk to God and and
fear not the demons of this world from
William Michael my girlfriend goes to
Bentley in Boston is currently helping
out there with orientation for her
introduction to new freshmen she's
required to say hi my name is Peyton my
pronouns are she her and hers well
you're very lucky that those are her
pronouns I'm pleased to hear that for
you
pronouns are also on the nametag she
hasn't comfortable saying this because
she believes there were only two genders
what would your advice be to her I would
never say that I would I would just
cross it out on my nametag and not say
it but look I'm pretty honest with my
views she might get some lower grades
because she does that but I wouldn't do
that at all I would and and if they
really make an issue out of it I'd
transfer to a more sane school that's
insane it's an assault not only on
reason but on the English language and
if the English language is being
battered at your university without any
safe haven perhaps you should leave that
University I would be very honest but
again there's a cost to that especially
these days in this culture so if she
doesn't want to deal with that cost then
she's got to toe the party line but I
would sleep very soundly at night if I
if I said no to that and didn't pretend
that there are 75 genders from Aaron how
many more I'll try to get through a
couple more from Aaron dang Noel's you
viciously excoriated Peter struck on
your show this week while I fully
approve I don't think I've ever seen you
Hulk out like this given the rampant
hypocrisy and negative press
scoff FA from the left Y was struck of
all people the one to finally push you
over the edge when can we expect a visit
from Hulk Michael right now baby that's
when you can because struck is such a
little twerp such a little wimpy
disgusting twerp that's why he's it's so
egregious look do it he cheated on his
wife a lot of people cheat on their
wives it's not good but that wouldn't be
enough to make me rip my shirt off and
turn green what drives me crazy is that
he used a bureaucratic position of the
public trust he abused it to threaten
the most obvious example of my freedom
the biggest most public most widespread
national example of my political freedom
is that I get to vote in major elections
like the presidential election for
instance he threatened and boasted about
subverting that from his weaselly little
power as a bureaucrat in the
administrative state and and then he put
his hand out after taking taxpayer money
his whole life he put his hand out to
get on the dole again I don't know he's
probably raised millions of dollars at
this point kept upping it they're the
left is giving him a trust fund to own
the cons it's so egregious but the thing
that really got me about him is is that
his weasel enos both abused the public
trust and threatens my freedom and I
don't like that from Matt Michael where
do you draw the line between being
willing to change your mind based on new
facts versus standing firm in your
beliefs how can we avoid confirmation by
eschewing the way we interpret new
information and is that even a bad thing
I'm always open to new information
that's how I've arrived at most of my
views is it our views that I didn't hold
before and then someone convinced me I'm
oh there is no there's no I say I won't
think about this I'm open to entertain
any book any idea any argument and
that's how I've arrived at my views we
should be perfectly willing to do that
and you'll become smarter and you'll
become firmer in your views to do that
I'm very open I come to questions with a
point of view with a vision of the world
as I see it so I am honest with myself
about that because then I'll do my best
to disprove to argue against my own
point of view if those arguments succeed
then I'll change my point of view
otherwise I'll keep going and to keep
being right another question from Aaron
is that the same Aaron maybe dear dr.
khofifah usually I listen to your show
an audio-only but today I happen to
watch the video and I noticed that you
wear your watch
your right hand good god man are you
left-handed I am spawn of the devil
absolutely sinister and I died two years
earlier on average I'm hoping that's
just because of mechanical accidents and
not because of something in our
handedness but yeah it's really rough I
also the main reason I've been doing it
these days because I've worn my watch on
my left before is it seems too blingy
with my wedding ring seems like really
blingy to have all that stuff on one
hand so I'm balancing it out I need a
lot of balance will do one more than I
got to get at here Steven Michael do you
think father rut ler would be a good
guest for Ben Shapiro's Sunday night
interview yes father mutlar is a
national treasure he's he's one of the
greatest guys in the country and has
more insight than virtually anybody I've
talked to he definitely should be on
there and I got to bring him back on my
show more as well okay that's our show
I hope I'm exhausted this is what
happens when you don't do any work for
two days then you've got to do a lot of
work great great to be back everybody
I'll see you on Monday in the meantime
by the way you've got to start binging
the first season of another Kingdom
because we're recording season 2 and it
is real cool so in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Moore show I'll see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018